>> I'm Jim Wallis.
And here at Davos, many people are understanding
underneath the
economic crisis is a values crisis.
We won't get to an economic recovery without
a moral recovery shaping
that, a moral compass for the new economy.
So we've been having sessions here.
And in previous years, if you wanted to talk
about social conscience,
social values at Davos, you had to get up
at 7:00 a.m. and go to the
fourth floor and you'd hear people like me
and Mohammed Yunus talk
about this.
But on the first day of Davos, Mohammed and
I were on the main floor
taking about the need for social business
or social conscience for
purposeful economies and for a moral economy.
And many people are very receptive to that
here.
We've been overtaken by these new maxims,
greed is good, it's all about
me, and I want it now.
We have to replace those with some older virtues
like enough is enough,
we're in this together, and I love the indigenous
people's ethic, who
evaluate decisions today by their impact on
the 7th generation out.
So we talked about the bad morality play of
banks and bailouts and
bonuses.
And how the massive bank bonuses in the face
of massive economic
suffering is, in my language, a sin of biblical
proportions.
And how people are moving their money from
the big banks to local
banks.
And we say that if banks are too big to fail,
we say make them smaller.
So people are talking about citizens' movements
now to bring values
back in this conversation.
I've just written a book called, "Rediscovering
Values on Wall Street,
Main Street, and Your Street."
And we had a launch to the book last night.
And I've been pleased by the conversation
between business leaders,
labor leaders, community organizers, religious
leaders, and lots of
lots of young people.
So it's a new conversation now.
We had the discussion on Jon Stewart last
Wednesday night.
I think that we're ready now for a new conversation
about values.
If we don't have that, all the suffering and
pain of this recession
will have been in vain.
But we have a values conversation maybe the
great recession could be
redemptive after all.
I hope so.